[Music]
[Applause]
Jay Morrison covers the Bengals for the
athletic he joins us on the program
uh how would you sum up what has
happened here in the last 72 hours or
longer than that Jay
uh traumatic for sure on Monday night
um a lot of questions uh going into
yesterday and then the a cloud just
lifted yesterday when they got news
before their morning walk out that Demar
was communicating
um it just it really lifted the mood of
this team I think there were there were
a lot of guys wondering should I play
um that I think has been there might be
some questions in the back of their mind
still but this that was huge news and
you could just feel it in the in the
locker room yesterday A lot of these
guys have not a lot of these guys but
some of them have personal relationships
with Demar and it you could you could
feel the weight lifted and just the way
they were communicating and acting was
there anything odd about the play with t
Higgins and Demar Hamlin
not really it looked like a standard
play you sometimes you see running backs
attack like that
um in in kind of lower to to initiate
contact it was a little odd to see a
receiver turn up feel that hard but he
didn't lead with the crown of his helmet
he was he was just going in and bracing
for what looked like a a regular
football tackle I'm wondering we got the
update from Shams earlier today the
breathing tube is out of Demar Hamlin
and he started talking to his Buffalo
Bills teammates something like that how
that affects the Bengals you mentioned
that you know a sense of relief
yesterday but now you get something like
this it almost and I don't want to speak
for them but I'm just wondering you know
does this allow them then to go in with
that maybe not on their mind as much as
they got to play a football game an
important one against the Ravens
yeah that's exactly it I I think
there'll be a little bit of trepidation
and a little bit of concern in pregame
once they start the game it's going to
feel like a regular football game they
there's only one way you can play this
game so I don't think anybody's going to
be tender footing it around and as much
as people like to complain maybe the NFL
did the Bengals a favor by putting this
coin flip possibility in play if that
wasn't maybe you see them sleepwalking
through this game a little bit because
they would have known they already had
the division clinched and they would
host next week next week now that's not
guaranteed if they lose this game
there's a good chance they're they're
still division champs they would have to
go on the road okay what do you think
the Bengals how are they going to react
to what's going to happen today at noon
when the owners vote on this playoff
scenario
uh I think they're going to be irate I I
think they're right now still working
the phones uh almost like a uh a
Survivor TV show tribal counselor well
you're trying to Garner enough votes to
to thwart this the outcome they need
they need eight other owners to join
them you need nine total no votes to to
Nix this proposal I I it it's
interesting because it doesn't just
affect the Bengals it affects everybody
that you've never seen them change the
rules
mid-season I mean we all grew up with
that annoying kid that wanted to change
the rules in the in the middle of the
game and now the NFL's trying to do that
and I think even teams that aren't in
the playoffs that aren't affected might
have pause thinking well what are they
going to do next time if this set's a
precedent but they can change the rules
in the middle of the Season maybe this
isn't the best way to go but also
there's that delicate balance though Jay
of the the pr look or public you know
the public reaction to this if the
Bengals are complaining about this I
know Joe Joe Mixon came out and said I
didn't know we could change you know the
rules and he's got a point there but I
just wonder how did the Bengals approach
this without that public backlash
well again I because I don't think it
just affects them it does affect them
but um you know the Chiefs
can't be thrilled with this because they
they if they win Saturday they're the
number one seed and then they still have
a possibility of a neutral site for the
AFC Championship game
um there's a lot of there's a lot at
stake here and I I I think I don't think
the pr aspect is that there's the
camaraderie between Buffalo and
Cincinnati has been amazing this week
and it goes back to 2017 when when Andy
Dalton had that late touchdown pass put
the bills in the playoffs the Bills fans
donated all this money to Andy's
Foundation Andy in turns donates
millions of dollars to the Buffalo
Children's Cancer Hospital there's just
this great relationship between the fan
bases and I I don't think anyone would
blame the Bengals for looking out for
the best interest in this case it's not
going to hurt Buffalo to do away with
this proposal yeah that's those are
great points there Jay you know when the
Bengals started out two and three
what did if I would have said hey this
team is good enough to go to the Super
Bowl here at the end of the year they're
not afraid of anybody would you have
said that after the first couple of
weeks
you know I would have said the roster
was good enough but are they going to
get it figured out in time it's funny
because it's two and three that was a
loss to the Ravens that put them at two
and three and this the Ravens are the
team they play today or on Sunday and
they they they learned some things in
that game they have totally changed the
way they approach Red Zone after that
game they tried a Philly special down
inside the five it didn't work a shovel
pass those decisions cost them the game
they've listed Joe burrow does not like
to go under Center they've they've
changed their running game now and
unless it's goal line or third and one
fourth and one they're they're running
out of the gun ever since that night
um it's just I I would have thought it
was possible but not likely but since
that game since two and three and they
and they changed some things they're on
a heater they go in 10 out of 11 7 in a
row and they absolutely look like a
Super Bowl team right now how would you
sum up Joe Burrows demeanor
um calm cocky no I don't say cocky
confident not quite cocky is cocky at
times
um reserved
um he he's not a guy he's he is all
football he you you have to force him to
do outside media he so far this he he's
done one commercial he's not interested
in endorsements he's done one awkward
commercial where he smells a pineapple
in the aisle of a grocery store
um no Cincinnati media member has had a
one-on-one with him yeah this is his
third season
um he does his his weekly news
conference he's he's been
accepting of that but he hasn't been
great Wednesday after the the Demar
thing happened he was fantastic his best
press conference of the year he was open
he was honest and uh he gave a little
peek into his personality a little more
of a peek into his personality that day
why do you think he shies away from that
we I mean Andrew Luck was like that when
he first came in he didn't do any
commercials RG3 got him all but uh Joe
certainly exudes that confidence where
you would think he would be cashing in
off the field as well
oh yeah he would be great I mean he has
the look he he has the attitude it's
just I don't think it interests him he
is 100 football I I have no doubt that
that he leaves the stadium every day
goes home and gets dinner and he's
probably in bed by nine or ten and then
up early the next morning watching film
it's just he is a hundred percent
football all the time before I let you
go the proximity of the hospital to the
stadium in Cincinnati is what
how many miles
two miles it's about a 10 minute drive
by car in normal traffic obviously the
ambulance would get there much faster
maybe four or five minutes
um it's it's right up the road near the
university and what's on the University
of Cincinnati Campus so uh yeah this is
very close that's where Ryan Shazier
went um when he was paralyzed on the
field this same field in a Prime Time
game in 2016. uh he he often credits
them with saving his his life saving his
career and not saying his career but
saving him and allowing him to be able
to resume walking
Jay good to talk to you thank you for
the insights and uh good luck this
weekend all right thanks Dan that's uh
Jay Morrison the Bengals beat writer for
the Athletics some good stuff there